اهلا بكم الى موجز الاخبار من الجزيره قبل
الرئيس الاوكراني
ان القوات الاوكرانيه تقاتلوا من اجل
تحقيق النصر في مواجهه الغزو الروسي وفي
لقاء مع سفراء اوكرانيا في الخارج عقبه
عودته من واشنطن حيث حصل على تعهدات بدعم
النوعي كشفها زيلين سكينه
ستوسعه جغرافيه النفوذ الاوكراني
المتحده نتوليا تنظف بين مخاطر اصطدام بين
روسيا والولايات المتحده مرتفعه واكد ان
تنظم
بانها ستكون اهدافها المشروعه في اوكرانيا
مدير الاستخبارات العسكريه الاوكرانيه
تحالفا بين مؤسسي مجموعه فاجنر وقائد
القوات الروسيه في اوكرانيا
تموجبه نقل اسلحه ثقيله من القوات الروسيه
الى مقاتلي فاجنر واضافها بودانو بان هذا
الاتفاق ادى الى توسيع دوري المجموعات في
الحرب الدائره باوكرانيا وعشره مدير
الاستخبارات العسكريه في مقابله مع
نيويورك
يبقى احتمالا ضعيفا على حد قوله من جهه
اخرى قال بودانو لن تتسرع وتقدم الصواريخ
البالستيه لروسيا واكد ان موسكو تسلم الفن
وسبع عام 200 مسيره ايرانيه الصنع من طراز
الشاهد واستخدمت منها حتى الان
540 مسيره
قال نائبه رئيس الوزراء الروسي الكسندر
نوفا كينا روسيا قد تقلص انتاجها من النفط
بما يتراوح بين 557 العام المقبل ردا على
اجراءات الغرب وضع سقف الاسعار النفط
والمنتجات البتروليه الروسيه وفيما سجلت
الاسواق وارتفاعا في اسعار النفط النقالات
وكاله توداس عن نوفاك قوله ان التخفيضات
قد تتراوحو بين 500,000 و700,000 برميل
يوميا وعشران
البتروليه الى الدولي والكيانات القانونيه
التي ستطلب الامتثاله لسقف الاسعار في
العقود
اعلنت النيابه العامه الفرنسيه مقتل ثلاثه
اشخاص واصابه اخرين في اطلاق نار وسط
باريس ونقلت رويترز عن المحامي ان القتل
الثلاثه هم من افراد الجاليه الكرديه
المحليه اقل مراسل الجزيره من الشرطه
تعتقلت مطلق النار وهو رجل فلسطيني وفتحت
تحقيقا في الحادثه وحولت التحقيقا لشرطه
مكافحه الجرائم
وقد اندلعت مواجهه بين الشرطه الفرنسيه
وافراد من الجاهليه الكرديه في العاصمه
باريس احتجاجا على مقتل في حادثه اطلاق
النار
شكرا على المتابعين وكنتم طلبت اوقاتكم
بكل